uh let's talk about the kansas city
chiefs the team that
lost to the buccaneers in the super bowl
week two sunday night football this was
one of the most anticipated games on the
schedule
last year the date with the ravens the
team that refers to the chiefs as their
kryptonite
week two no screwing around early on
chiefs at ravens that is a sneaky great
game that we're gonna have on nbc chris
yeah a hundred percent i mean how could
you not lamar patrick mahomes
mahomes has the number of this great
baltimore ravens defense
they kind of know it they're not going
to back down from the challenge
you know mike they might be one of those
teams you know that we talked about
yesterday about how you prepare for the
early season
games uh the ravens with their issues
with the chiefs they they might take a
week at some point in the offseason and
go let's practice what the chiefs do
and just get a little head start on all
of that but
man that's always awesome i mean that
that that to me is yes an
early early awesome football game with
major playoff implications could come
down to who wins the tiebreaker and
seating and everything like that but
anytime mahomes and lamar on we're
watching
and then three weeks later bill's chiefs
holy crap wow what what
what a start to the season and i don't
want to
be one of those guys that that like goes
over the top
about the schedule that our network got
but holy crap
i mean really you get the cowboys bucks
out of the gates you got ravens chiefs a
week later then you got
buccaneers and uh and patriots we've
already discussed in the week after that
you got bill's chiefs and i think
there's a 49ers sunday night game
sandwiched in there as well
yeah no i it's a pretty strong schedule
we got we certainly shouldn't be bored
or worried about our matchups this year
on sunday night football that's for sure
but you know you look at kansas city
those those first three games they're
tricky
when you look at the schedule you know
again the browns got great belief and
their
their playoff game in there last year is
only going to give them confidence to
think that they can go in there and win
another football game
and then they're going to look at
themselves and go wait we're a better
team we're bringing in
you know some different studs this time
around too john johnson's here
deviant clown is here you know those
type of players that's going to change
that aspect
ravens are going to be foaming at the
mouth and we know the chargers are up
and coming so that's a tricky little
start of the
year for the kansas city chiefs and i
hope they're not you know
pouting about their super bowl loss for
for too much
i was on 106 7 the fan yesterday with
the junkies talking about that chargers
washington game right out of the gates
look i want to get the chargers early
if i can week one that's when washington
gets in week three that's when the
chiefs get him the first time
that week 15 game that chargers team is
going to be a lot better chris
i mean agreed not that it's going to be
bad early but if i want to get a team
that i feel like is on the rise kind of
under the radar on the rise
i want them early i don't want them when
they have become what they're going to
be
yeah talented under the radar big
time quarterback you know a new head
coach so the defense is going to be
learning the new system
new offensive coordinator with joe
lombardi out there and everything like
that
so that is the time to catch them that
hopefully they're
you know if you're the chiefs or a team
that's playing those chargers yeah
hopefully they're not used to
the new style of football which they're
playing out there and you catch them but
yeah the chargers are again i think mike
again another one of those teams
that you just put out there to go hey
every year we see it
teams that don't make the playoffs
somehow find a way in the next year
i mean the chargers we know they're
capable of being a playoff
football team it's just going to be
interesting to see how that coaching
unit and players all come together
five prime time games in all for the
kansas city chiefs subject to the
possibility of a week 10 flex although
it usually takes a lot to get a flex to
kick in before week 11.
that's the sunday night game at the las
vegas raiders week 15 thursday nighter
at the chargers
that obviously won't be flexed monday
night week 8 against the giants
so we'll see plenty of patrick mahomes
again this year we'll see plenty of
patrick mahomes every year that he's in
the nfl
because he's one of the best players
that's ever played the game and
they like to get those big games in big
spots and they have several of them
this year they play playoff teams from
last year in five of their first seven
games though so the chiefs had better be
ready to go out of the gates no
slippage early and we know this is a
team last year that really only lost one
regular season game that they were
trying to win their second loss came
week 17 they didn't start patrick
mahomes so they they have been on a
regular season roll
for an extended period of time really
ever since my homes came back from the
knee injury in 2019
they've been virtually unbeatable uh
yeah they have i mean
they're always ready to play i mean when
they're not ready to play
it's like right mike it's almost like
okay they're playing down to the level
of this team a little today
but like you never get the sense that
they're really going to lose even when
they do do that you just feel like ah
they're they're
they're being the chiefs they're messing
around they'll find the gas pedal here
at some point
but you're right i don't think they got
that luxury this year you know with the
schedule this schedule
was definitely one of the ones to me
that jumped out where i just went
whoa that's pretty tough right there i
mean other than the eagles week four
i mean every one of those teams and
rosters they're about to play especially
the first
nine weeks of the year up to that
packers game on the left column there
i mean even the teams that you look at
like washington i know we don't look at
them as like a juggernaut
but damn we we've seen we know that
defense is good
they got they're going to get better on
that side of the ball signing william
jackson all of that i mean that would
they're an up and coming team
and even the giants at eight where those
are two games you look at and go
well kansas city should win like i
you know yeah okay i know but it's not
going to be easy those are going to be
two
very improved football teams with really
good defenses and creative defensive
coordinators
to where i look at this chief schedule
and i wouldn't be shocked to see them
maybe you know uh six and three
or you know at one point four and three
and kind of like struggling to find
their way here early on in the year
well and if that's the case goodbye to
the buy because there's only one
available and chances are there's going
to be another team
yeah somebody when you got that many
teams somebody's going to get off to an
ultra hot start in the afc
i guess there's always a chance they're
going to cluster around you know 500
but if they stumble early then you know
you have to assume at some point you're
going on the road in the postseason not
that they can't win on the road but you
always want to be at home if you can
week nine if you noticed
at the bottom of that first column
that's the packers game at kansas city
that's the game that's the result for
the chiefs and the packers
of the 17th game the extra game that
wasn't previously on the schedule an
inner conference battle based on
a rotation by divisions and where you
finished in your division first place
afc west first place
nfc north packers at the chiefs
4 25 pm eastern on a sunday
and i assume that if aaron rodgers is
not playing for the packers they'll be
able to
swap that out for a broncos game that
week i didn't check the broncos schedule
week nine but
if all else fails and i'm gonna do that
now while we speak but if all else fails
you can put a broncos game at 425 in
there
oh they play that day at one o'clock
eastern
against the cowboys oh well that's an
easy they can always
slide 25. slide that to 425 man there
you go it's either going to be
it's either going to be chiefs packers
or aaron rodgers
back in dallas on that day that that i
mean i mean it's no coincidence i mean
you
i know you watched a little the nfl
channel the draft stuff last night and
everything like that
that one point they talked about this
little element and that
you know the nfl network they they put
out their investigative reporters and
all their people
for all their connections really to
figure out the rogers situation
and you know there was they they
admitted that there was a lot of thought
by the nfl
be of the packers and broncos schedule
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports